intended people thought good arrived got  it under control  [Music]  that's a really bad sign  guardians of the galaxy vol 2 City pg-13  may fit the piece hyacinth takes to be  placed on the outside that must cut to  it from the inside  [Music]  [Applause]  what is he doing he said this unit to  specially beers on the outside I think  of the mystery food my mother will fix  it from the inside is from the outside I  realize that  here's a cut on its neck talk it get it  to look  [Music]  [Music]  the sovereign the Ravagers  they all want us dead that's a really  bad sign  The Guardian happy destroy  give me with your best shot  oh wow no and almost hit me good tickets  now  you